c'est une première à plus d'un titre un
référé déposé simultanément en
martinique et en guadeloupe un référé
qui ici mais ensemble la sopa marc la
cstm un chef d'entreprise et une dizaine
d'avocats
leur objectif forcer les autorités
sanitaires à prendre des décisions pour
protéger la population du coc vite 19
se basant sur l'exemple de la corée et
de l'allemagne qui a dépisté à grande
échelle
les requérants demandent ainsi par
exemple la généralisation des tests de
dépistage
vous savez en ce moment nous avons une
suspicion où tout le monde parce que le
voisin est atteint de chloé ou aux
navires us dans pour éviter cela elle
nous donne plus demandeur de faire un
dépistage systématique sur toute la
population ça permettra quoi ça
permettra déjà de savoir si on est déjà
impactés par ce virus
et ça permettra aussi bas d'isoler ceux
qui sont impactés et d'arrêter justement
cette propagation
il réclame également de rendre
accessible le traitement préconisé par
l'institut méditerranée du professeur
raoul
ils réclament des équipements comme les
masques alors qu'une commande géante
vient d'être passé en chine
il demande enfin que les médecins
cubains puisse exercer ici
le référé a été déposé en martinique le
26 mars le 27 pour la guadeloupe
mais le tribunal de guadeloupe a déjà
statué donnant raison aux requérants une
décision déjà qualifié par un avocat
martinique et de jurisprudences domota